(upbeat music)
(audience applauds)
- My favorite part is
the lunch tray aspect.
- What's happening?
- Is that jalapeno cheddar sausage?
- I believe it is.
This is the regular sausage,
and then this is jalapeno.
Last time we talked
about Cooper's Barbecue.
- [Kelly] Yes.
- Having trouble finding good
barbecue places out here.
So I was like, you know what,
my friends at Cooper's,
they were like, we gotta
get Kelly some barbecue.
- You just trump him.
You're my favorite guest.
Just kidding. (laughs)
- Mine too.
- He brought food.
- I did bring food-
- From Texas.
- But for everybody.
Yeah, they flew it out.
- This is from Texas?
Oh, my god.
- It's here.
- It looks really good.
- What's the protocol
on eating the food?
Like how-
- It's right now.
- I think it's we dig into these.
- Do I let y'all talk for
a little bit and then...
Okay, cool.
- Its for everybody.
- Cool, cool, cool,
cool, cool, cool, cool.
- Please.
- It's so good.
- I know.
- Oh my god, wait.
You gotta get the jalapeno cheddar.
- We got brisket.
We got ribeye, we got sausage.
- I'll let you guys talk for
a little bit and I'll be...
- Oh.
That's my...
- Yeah, the sausage.
- That's my jam.
- Right?
Oh, my god.
- I know.
I wish I had enough for everybody.
Sorry.
- I know.
- This is from Cooper's.
And this is next door to Billy Bob's.
Is that where we were talking
about last time, right?
- Yes.
- I perform to Billy Bob's.
I never had this.
- Well, there's a first
time for everything.
Now you can go back.
- Oh, my gosh, it's so good.
God, I love that.
- This is tasty as...
- So wait, you're from St. Louis.
What's barbecue like there?
- St. Louis has great barbecue.
My brother is a barbecue artist.
He's got this huge egg
that can smoke for like 12 to 24 hours.
- Oh, my mouth is watering.
- And then just rib tips
falling off the bone.
But this is tasty, too.
So, you know, respect
to Texas, it's all good.
- Okay.
- All good.
- Healthy competition is good.
- Amen.
- That drives innovation, right?
- Absolutely.
- Y'all keep keep talkin'.
- Okay, well, speaking of barbecue,
so what were your summer
vacations like as a kid?
What did you do?
- Okay, so the reason
that I found Cooper's was
because I used to go to
summer camp as a kid.
I went to a camp called Camp Champions.
It was a three week sleepaway
camp in Marble Falls, Texas.
- Oh, my god.
- It's right on Lake LBJ.
- Yeah, yeah.
- Okay, yeah.
- Apparently, Drew Brees went there too.
If anybody would-
- Oh, my god.
- Yeah, weird, but-
- Fancy camp.
- So it was a sports camp.
And that's where I discovered pickleball.
You ever played that?
- I've heard of pickleball.
I've never played it.
- Pickleball is fun.
I'm a big tennis guy
but I was early on the pickleball train.
- Yeah.
- Okay.
- It's ping pong standing
on the table, basically, right?
- That is a great way of putting it, yes.
- Okay, yeah.
- Is that really kind of what it is?
- Yeah, pretty much.
- I would love it.
- It's like a Wiffle ball type of thing
with a paddle.
- Okay.
- Yeah.
- Mm-hmm.
- Did you do camp as a kid?
- I did.
I didn't go away for three weeks though.
Black people didn't do that kind of thing.
(Jaren and Kelly laugh)
You go to camp and you come
home at the end of the day.
- So wait, you play a nerd on the show,
but on a magazine, look at this.
This is the hottest picture ever.
What is this for?
- Oh, yeah.
(audience cheers)
- Thank you.
Yeah, so I was-
- I need you to play this character.
- I would love to play that character.
What happened was we
were like, you know what?
I want people to see me in
a bit of a different light.
- [Kelly] Well done.
- Thank you.
- [Kelly] Yes.
- I like to exercise.
- It's cool with art as well,
to see people not in type cast.
- Well, you did the same thing.
I remember I was watching "This Is Us,"
I think it was the first season,
and your character Randall
had a shirtless scene.
And all of a sudden I was like, oh my god.
This man's ripped, too.
- Yeah.
- Let's go.
Like, for the nerds.
- Nerds work out.
- Totally.
- Yeah, we work out too.
- Yeah.
(audience cheers)
- I'm a ripped nerd as well.
- Yes.
- Totally, here's my shirtless moment.
I'm just kidding.
(all laugh)
No, just kidding.
So let's talk about "Never Have I Ever."
So this is the last season.
- It is the last season.
- So kind of bittersweet.
It's been so much fun, but it's ending.
So do you think fans will
be happy with how it ends?
Or do you think they'll-
- I think, and for fans out there
that are watching right now
and that are in the audience,
I genuinely don't think
that there could have
been a better ending.
- Oh.
- As a whole.
For every character,
no matter who you love,
no matter what storylines
that you identify with
or find yourself in.
- Way to go writers.
- Oh, my god, the writers,
they went crazy this season.
- Okay.
- They really gave you
the perfect sendoff.
You know, there are certain
shows where it ends,
and you're like, man,
that just wasn't what I
wanted for the ending.
- Yeah.
- Granted, my character Ben Gross,
there's a bit of a love triangle.
For those that watch and
those that don't, get on it.
- Can we give it up, this man is awesome.
Kill the game.
- Thank you, you too.
- You're welcome.
- But there will be a winner
for that love triangle.
I can't say who, you will find out.
So one of that side of the fandom
is probably gonna be disappointed.
And the other side's
gonna be really excited,
so, we'll see.
Tune in June 8th.
- All right.
You kind of set it up though.
Now if people are upset,
they're gonna be like, I blame him.
- That's fine.
- I'm just kidding.
- That's fair.